four million Americans are in the path
of a powerful weather system churning in
the Gulf of Mexico tropical storm
watches and warnings are in effect for
parts of the Gulf Coast chief weather
caster Lonnie Quinn of our New York
station wcbs-tv is here Lonnie where's
the storm gonna hit okay it looks like I
would say the Big Bend area of Florida
but let's talk about the storm right now
okay you take a look at the picture and
it's already pushed sort of east of New
Orleans so I say New Orleans you know
you're out of that area of concern but
the winds are blowing at 40 miles per
hour this is possibly tropical storm
Nestor right now we cannot find the
organization for it to be called the
tropical storm but it could very well be
so in the next 24 hours we were to the
Northeast at 14 miles per hour it's
gonna bring winds maybe 40 50 miles per
hour
onshore rain as well but come with me
this way I want to talk about the rain
because there are portions of our
country that need rain more than
anything else and it happens to be right
where this storm is headed take a look
okay at the deficits you have right now
in a place like Dothan Alabama Dothan
Alabama needs 17 inches of rain I mean
the rain bucket is bone-dry
Tallahassee needs 17 inches Orangeburg
20 inches below where they should be
since January 1 and if you look at the
track remember those towns watch this it
is gonna move almost right on top of the
towns that need the water the most in
the amount of rain that we're talking
about here well the rain totals are
coming in anywhere from about two to
five inches that yellow color shows you
the to the foot the red color charge you
have for overall general thought is that
maybe two to five inches of rain for
places that really needed anthems go
radio Nora Lonnie thank you